[Musique]
s'il faut ou pas pour je n'ai pas osé
j'ai tout dans les bureaux
si dans trois coups je suis sentimentale
mais aussi des passions des dons qui
es-tu bel enfant de saloon je suis
nadine et mots que tu sais la fille du
roi dian et toi que tu bats l'étranger
je suis le guet je suis une nouvelle le
roi embaucher un gay il
quel joli mais je vais me faire un nom
non non ce petit pas la ville en
totalisant études et pas vraiment mon
genre de beauté moi j'aime plutôt
skiable ce qui pique aussi
moi aussi j'adore ce qui pique on va
bien sans corps ni oui je le veux
redevenir copine en tout cas m'a dit tu
as ta ravissante et un teint de pêche
tient ce cru à se créer à nouveau gel
par la personne ah non je fais le soir
des masque d'argile rouge et des
infusions de thio c'est tout à fait ce
qu'il faudrait c'est pas terrible avance
toute la journée dans cette tour au
soleil je vous avais dit toute la
journée duo sonia ben oui forcément le
guet le guette oublie ça soit guéri tôt
et il va pas être facile le passage du
bon c'est pas tout non papa bah écoute
il est très occupé en ce moment c'est
vraiment plaisant mais c'est trop mal
j'avais quelque chose d'urgent du bien
je m'en fous que j'ai vécu et mordit
leurs torts à la puce
sympathique non que je suis heureux de
revoir il ya si longtemps de leur dose
je suis pas un univers nouvelle aventure
j'ai tendu par le pass 14 supporte la
mairie cus et bref je te raconte pas
tout tout ce que je peux te dire faire
tout n'a pas prêté d'argent depuis le
printemps dernier
je regrette mme ans fauchée j'ai des
dettes peux-tu me dépanner papa non je
suis encore plus content que la
télévision régionale je t'en prie aidez
moi
sans compter que j'attends toujours mon
reçu de la dernière fois mais papa juin
je me battrai pour ne rendre je te
rendrai tout en argent des panneaux à
faire un petit peu mon nom ça va ça va
ça va c'est quand il annonce lambé tiens
il ya quelqu'un pour toi qui va
peut-être temps donné la wii
monsieur tata nano peut valoir au ballon
et m'ont reçue à l'origine attends moi
ne tend pas pas en jade or quand ça
défile comme ça ils ont bien en ce
moment ça me rappelle dallas suis issu
en fin de salon
contentons-nous je n'ai pas froid ou
vous
bon boulot
[Musique]